und ich weiß ja nicht wie es ihnen geht
verehrte zuschauer aber für mich hat das
gute alte spd bashing in den letzten
tagen endgültig seinen reiz verloren es
macht keinen spaß mehr
jetzt haben sie auch noch ihre erste
weibliche vorsitzende aus dem amt
gedrängt im willy brandt haus in berlin
stehen schon über so warnschilder
vorsicht frisch gemacht meine damen und
herren
ja andrea nahles hat hingeschmissen
rücktritt von allen ämtern
da fragt man sich wirklich warum noch
spd wählen ich habe die letzten sonntag
als mit lachs wiedergewählt aber nicht
nur das mitleid ja ja ja müsste man mal
ausrechnen wo die spd ohne das ganze
mitleid stehen würde
andrea nahles gerade mal 13 monate im
amt
das ist wirklich etwas mehr als einem
jahr ist doch traurig dass traurig war
der umgang der spd mit andrea nahles am
ende vielleicht sogar frauenfeindlich
das wird ja gerade diskutiert in
deutschland ich meine nein denn die
partei wandelt alle ihre vorsitzenden
gleich scheiße
wie soll man da noch freiwillige finden
vielleicht so du bist jung extrem
belastbar und fällen von gerechtigkeit
tarifbindung und all dem sozial gewöhnt
dann wird doch spd vorsitzende
wir bieten dir einen sicheren job für
mehrere monate war leitete eine der zehn
wichtigsten parteien deutschlands mit
super kollegen die den ganzen tag offen
sagen wie sie dich finden
bogdan bewirbt sich jetzt bei der
sozialdemokratischen partei deutschlands
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der vorreiter machen will
verrückter gedanke vor dem wer soll's
machen denn der spitze könnte man sich
jetzt so abwechslung auch mal fragen was
wollen wir machen als spd aus merkels
regierungszeit unnötig verlängern
stattdessen wieder nur personaldebatten
jetzt hat es so eine art ja übergangs
trio zwangsverpflichtet quasi den
volkssturm der spd ja dreier schwesig
schäfer gümbel alle im falschen moment
ans telefon gegangen so wer von euch
hassen hat den lustigen job dauerhaft zu
machen
ich will das für mich persönlich sagen
mein platz ist in mecklenburg vorpommern
für mich ist es ja schon lange total
klar dass ich als ministerpräsidentin in
rheinland-pfalz wieder antreten möchte
ich selber habe ja entschieden mitte des
nächsten halbjahres aus der politik aus
zuschauen wirklich thorsten wie schade
ist das denn
schäfer gümbel wechselt übrigens ist
kein witz ab oktober in die
entwicklungshilfe
da kann auch bei der spd bleiben findet
ein super trio echt ganz ehrlich mehr
neuanfang geht wirklich nicht
wäre da nicht auch was frischeres
gegangen was ist denn zum beispiel mit
kevin kühnert kevin könnte das reißen
ich wollte wenigstens mal gefragt haben
die spd sage ich ihnen muss raus aus der
gruppe man kann auch sterben vor lauter
staatspolitischer verantwortung jetzt
sind einfach mal andere dran
soll doch gefälligst die grünen in
muttis häckselmaschine springen oder die
pizza von der fdp
mal ernsthaft wie viele vorsitzende soll
die arme spd dennoch verbrennen hier
neue maxi-cd wohl der schicht im schacht
der spd steiger chor sind die namen
aller spd-vorsitzenden endlose zwei
stunden lang die namen von völlig zu
recht vergessenen spd chef
[Musik]
und als bonus track dass pippi
langstrumpf lied in der andrea nahles
version
die wir lieben
[Musik]
schicht im schacht hoffentlich ist es
bald vorbei
[Applaus]
wenn man darüber nachdenkt der große
wählerschwund geht im kern immer noch
zurück auf die schröder jahre als der
grundstein gelegt wurde für unsere neun
millionen niedriglöhner und wenn die spd
von heute weiß dass man zwölf euro
mindestlohn kriegen müsste um im alter
mehr zu haben als grundsicherung dann
besteht man auf 12 euro oder verlässt
die regierung ende die groko ist doch
sowieso längst im freien fall
rote linie festlegen die groko ist kurz
vorm auseinander fliegen denn der cdu
geht es auch nicht viel besser als den
sozen immerhin das wird sie freuen hat
der kleine philipp am tor
sie lachen nicht über den namen der
kleine philipp otto hat jetzt endlich
verraten wie seien nie gesendet dass
antwort videoanrufe so ausgesehen hätte
den kleinen spoiler mache ich jetzt
daran fantastisch hey wieso du alter
zerstört
so war der erste satz war wie cool
beziehungsweise überhaupt nicht wenn
sogar markus lanz sich fremdschämen
meine damen und herren auch die union
muss doch beten das ist nicht zu
neuwahlen kommen nur 18 prozent der
deutschen trauen gerade annegret
kramp-karrenbauer das kanzleramts u18
noch vor ein paar monaten wissen sie ist
es überall
let's make annegret again aber jetzt ist
die euphorie komplett verflogen ja zu
recht ihr ganzes nach rechts geblinkt
wird zu über dritte toiletten oder neue
regeln fürs internet treibt massenweise
cdu wähler zu den grünen und annegret
reden na ja wir haben in dieser klausur
vor allen dingen darüber diskutiert wie
wollen wir in zehn bis 20 jahren leben
und wovon wollen wir in zehn bis 20
jahren leben und noch wichtiger was
wollen wir trinken sieben tage lang
wollen wir leben
ich hatte wolf von geld an greta
abwarten ob acker überhaupt
kanzlerkandidatin wird an stühlen gesägt
wird nämlich auch in der union mobbing
und intrigen ziehen sich geradezu durch
die bundesdeutsche geschichte zufällig
ein absolutes spezialgebiet von mir
herzlich willkommen zum großen preis mit
dennis kraus salat
[Applaus]
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur finalrunde thema
die schönsten mobbing massaker der polit
geschichte unser kandidat ist der oliver
aus bielefeld er ist von beruf fernseher
ansager seine hobbys sind jazz tanz und
hausschlachtung die weil sie kennen die
regeln sobald hier 300 punkte haben
müssen sie im herbst den spd vorsitz
übernehmen verdammt gut dann nehme ich
abgesägte sitzen 20 welchen satz hört
man am häufigsten von ehemaligen
spd-chefs ich wünsche meiner partei
trotzdem alles gute
fast die spd weil manchmal eine richtig
scheiße partei schade oliver dabei war
es so einfach man muss jemanden wirklich
sehr hassen und spd vorsitz zu wünschen
schon wähler hat den brand fertiggemacht
selbst kurt beck haben sie geht ist
dabei war dass so ein netter mann immer
nah bei de leut ich glaube dass es ganz
wichtig ist dass wir
frauen halten im moment einfach
da
dafür gibt es keine punkte das war das
vorfall gab weiter geht's gut
diese verschwörer 40 ok ich zeige ihnen
ist eine szene direkt nach der berühmten
fraktionssitzung in der andrea nahles
zum aufhören gebracht wurde
aufpassen erkennen sie an körpersprache
oder aussehen einen der haupt
verschwörer
ich komme nicht darauf an sich müsste
ich raten ein kleiner tipp er war selber
mal parteichef franz müntefering
nee münchens damals aus dem amt jagt von
andrea nahles war es nicht martin schulz
wäre es gewesen der würselen asse
natürlich gut dann nehme ich gemobbte
kreise 60 sehr gut welche unbelehrbare
kreise csu vorsitzende seehofer
horst seehofer 218 viel zu spät abgesägt
von markus söder
das ist so etwas wie freundschaft unter
politikern ein beziehungsweise jetzt
richtige antwort geil wie viele punkte
kriege ich dafür 200.000 klasse sehr gut
dann nehme ich warte mal todeskuss von
mutti 100 kommen wir zur meisterin
niemand hat mehr karrieren zerstört als
angela merkel roland koch röttgen wulff
leichen pflastern ihren weg frage wen
schmeißt die kanzlerin als nächstes aus
balterswil könnte praktisch jeder sein
okay einen hinweis die
verteidigungsministerin hat die volle
unterstützung der bundeskanzlerin in der
ganzen bundesregierung
ja
das sieht es nicht aus
aber erst nächsten dienstag ist eine
überraschung so ohne fragt ja durch
welchen kollegen wird der moderator
einer erfolgreichen zdf satiresendung
nach zehn jahren im amt plötzlich und
während der laufenden sendung ersetzt
niemand wird in der laufenden sendung
ersetzt falsch richtige antwort ist
[Applaus]
bis 10
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag wünschen überall
lassen die ihre techniken liegen und ihr
lasst jetzt das xenix ein beschissenes
autobahn
[Musik]